et maintenant monsieur Jean-Marie
valrhenberg pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 7 minutes
[Applaudissements]
sur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la rapporteur généralisabeth
madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues de partout montent la même
complainte il faut plus plus d'argent
pour l'hôpital plus de médecins
soignants plus de crèche plus d'argent
pour les retraites plus de moyens pour
la 5ème branche donc vous parlera
d'ailleurs Jocelyne guidez bref autant
de questions mesdames et messieurs des
ministres pour le gouvernement et pour
nous une seule question le PLFSS 2023 il
répond-il vraiment
en apparence je dirais oui
avec 600 milliards pour les 5 branches
des dépenses sont supérieures de plus de
12 milliards à la prévision et le
déficit total et néanmoins ramené à 6
milliards 8 contre 17,8 l'an dernier la
dame progresse de 3,7 % orchiescovic
donc à son constant ce qui est
significatif mais les apparences ne
sont-elles pas trompeuses
seuls deux branches
sont à l'équilibre la famille la TMP et
les hypothèses ne sont-elles pas trop
optimistes l'assurance maladie accuse
encore un déficit de signats et demi et
l'hôpital va de crise en crise
urgence pédiatrique psychiatrique et ce
n'est pas en ponctionnant 2 milliards à
la branche famille concevra l'hôpital
l'hôpital est malade mais c'est tout
notre système de santé qu'il faut
soigner il est à bout de souffle son
mode de fonctionnement est à revoir
Emmanuel Macron a promis de ramener la
tarification à l'acte à 50% pour mieux
rémunérer la qualité et le travail en
équipe nous attendons donc monsieur le
ministre un plan d'action et surtout des
actes pour apporter à l'hôpital un
financement sain et pérenne le mode de
gouvernance aussi est à revoir
et point n'est besoin d'une loi
supplémentaire nous avons vu que les
établissements y sont parvenus le CH de
Valenciennes en particulier expérimente
un mode de fonctionnement antipyramidal
antibuocratique et ça marche plus
d'autonomie plus de délégation on fait
confiance aux médecins et à leurs
équipes pour raccourcir les décisions au
bénéfice bien sûr des patients et du
budget qui ne consacre plus que 5% à
l'administratif contre cinq fois plus
ailleurs le directeur canalisé qui
librent le budget et entretient
effectivement la paix sociale monsieur
le ministre la solution est là
n'attendons pas pour la généraliser il
faut aussi vous le savez
fluidifier le système de soins pour
désengorger l'hôpital et ses urgences la
clé existe lcps la coordination ville
hôpital est essentielle pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux et quand je
dis hôpital je pense bien sûr aussi aux
établissements privés l'amélioration de
la permanence des soins et l'accès aux
soins passe en effet par la mise en
place partout de ces pts comment
accepter que 40% des médecins de ville
seulement
assurent la garde de nuit et les
week-end si les médecins
veulent retrouver du temps médical il
doit déléguer aux autres soignants une
partie de leur travail je salue
d'ailleurs l'accord concluant ce sens
entre les différents ordres monsieur le
ministre vous parlez souvent de votre
boîte à outils les solutions existent et
elles marchent il faut les diffuser les
élus locaux sont prêts à faire les
efforts nécessaires pour que l'égalité
qui est inscrite au fronton des mairies
s'applique aussi dans l'accès aux soins
mais une question se pose
c'est l'économie du système les
professionnels réclament des plans
pluriannuels pour anticiper des
évolutions thérapeutiques et permettre à
notre pays de rester à la pointe du
progrès dans ce domaine cela mérite une
très grande attention et la dernière
question concerne les ressources la
première piste tous les ministres ont
utilisé c'est celle des économies la
source n'est pas tari elle est même je
crois abondante mais encore faut-il ne
pas se tromper longtemps longtemps la
ressource humaine a été présurée mal
rémunéré le Ségur a apporté un effet
salvateur mais il doit être poursuivi et
cela coûte d'autres pistes sont donc à
privilégier les actes redondants
inutiles représentent 20 à 30% de notre
système de soins soit 40 à 60 milliards
de dépenses à revisité
la HAS qui emploie mais vous avez ciblé
à peine plus d'un milliard d'économies
sur la radiologie la biologie les
médicaments dans votre projet c'est bien
mais insuffisant par ailleurs un autre
demande l'estimation des fraudes aux
cotisations et aux prestations est en
cours
la cnaval bon élève ont rendu leur
résultat par contre la CNAM est très en
retard si nous voulons éviter
l'exploitation fantasmée du montant de
ces fraudes il faut des chiffres et
rapidement
enfin un mot sur les retraites le
déficit et la dette se creusent une
réforme s'impose mais attention si nous
ne voulons pas mettre des millions de
personnes dans la rue il faut qu'elle
soit comprise et acceptée
l'amendement que notre collègue
René Paul Savary dont je salue la
compétence et la constance aussi dans
l'effort il répond-il partiellement
seulement à mes yeux en effet si je
crois utile la réunion d'une convention
nationale pour préparer la loi parce que
je suis partisan du paritarisme par
contre je ne partage pas le recul à 64
ans de l'âge de départ je retiens ce
qu'a dit ce qu'on dit le président de la
République et la première ministre
64 ou 65 ans ne sont pas des totems à
titre personnel je serai plutôt partisan
d'une fenêtre de départ comme le
préconise économistes gentils et Olivier
Blanchard dans leur rapport de 2021
l'âge moyen de départ étant d'ailleurs
de 62 ans et demi on pourrait simplement
le reculer à 63 ans
par justice parce que cette réforme doit
être juste j'entends les avancées
sociales sur la durée de cotisation pour
les quatre pardon pour les carrières
longues fracturées pour la pénibilité
par justice j'entends aussi le
relèvement des petites pensions
l'insertion des chômeurs de longueurées
et par justice j'entends aussi le
maintien au travail des seigneurs
licenciés prématurément selon Jean Hervé
Lorenzi l'activité des seigneurs
pourrait de plus rapporter 13 milliards
en 10 ans voyez pour conclure je salue
l'excellent travail de nos rapporteurs
et j'espère monsieur le ministre que
vous tiendrez compte pour le pour que le
sel vous en tiendrait compte pardon pour
que le Sénat trouve pleinement sa place
dans cette loi de 2023 merci chers
collègues
la parole est maintenant madame Esther
Benbassa pour les non inscrits pour 3
minutes